MARVIN ROTRAND conseiller de
ville indépendant, Snowdon, Mtl
- C'est difficile après 39 ans,
où j'ai travaillé presque
sept jours sur sept.
- 39 ans, ça nous ramène
en 1982.
♪♪♪
Montréal venait de perdre
son statut de métropole
du Canada au profit de Toronto.
Le Canadien s'était fait battre
en série pour la première fois
par les Nordiques. La Reine
rapatriait officiellement
la Constitution
et Marvin Rotrand faisait
sa première campagne à 31 ans,
contre l'administration Drapeau.
- J'ai été candidat avec
Jean Doré en 1982. J'ai été élu,
Jean est battu.
- Et il sera réélu à chaque fois
dans Snowdon et verra passer
sept maires et une mairesse.
Parmi ses accomplissements,
l'ouverture des micros à
l'hôtel de ville, en 1986.
- Nous avons, la première geste,
créé une période de question
pour les citoyens, pour leur
donner accès aux élus.
- Mais ce qu'il reprochait
au conseil municipal des années
80, c'était surtout son manque
de représentativité.
- Mon travail a largement
demandé que Montréal reconnaît
que c'est une ville
multiculturelle et multiraciale.
Quand je suis arrivé,
tout le monde est blanc
à l'hôtel de ville,
au conseil municipal.
- Dans ses souvenirs de moments
savoureux, lui qui s'opposait
aux fusions municipales, pioche
celui-ci.
- Je me souviens le fun que
j'avais eu quand j'ai prouvé que
la pétition de Pierre Bourque
avec 50 000 noms de Montréalais
en faveur de la fusion forcée. -
Ils ont vérifié 45 454
signatures, et ils en ont
éliminé la moitié.
- Et seulement 7000 noms
dans la même écriture
récoltée à la station de métro
avec beaucoup de Donald Duck et
de Mickey Mouse sur la liste, ç
a c'était fun.
- Et s'il vante ses années
en tant qu'élu indépendant qui
l'ont tenu loin des lignes de
parti, il finira son mandat
en tant qu'élu de l'opposition.
- Le slogan que Denis Coderre
utilise, Vivre ensemble,
ça a beaucoup de résonnance
avec moi, parce que mon travail,
pendant 40 ans, est dans
ce sens.
- Ce grand fidèle du conseil
municipal s'inquiète d'en
manquer des bribes, et tente de
se connecter au milieu du parc.
- Am I still on, I'm still on
here. Where's Iphone, not
showing up.
- Il lui reste encore
des motions à défendre avant
de laisser définitivement
la politique derrière lui.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, Mo